my name is Gloria  people call me Vela guess it's time to  face the cupcakes well a lot of people  call me traitor what if we fought the  monster instead of feeding it the grand  mogs have visited our lands for as long  as anyone can remember if you destroy  the feast  mog chothra will destroy this village  that's what I get for asking questions  why did we willingly offer sacrificial  maidens for that beast to devour we were  once a village of warriors we had pride  in Honor this can't be right  I know that if I act on my instinct to  fight I would be putting my whole  village in danger so I'll ask Annie  requestor instead of what if we fought  the monster what I want to know is how  do I kill it